- Is it hot in here?
- Is it?
- You are hot.
(Hip Hop song)
- I am Donnie Rock.
I am an adult male performer.
- I am Tori Black and I am here
with the lovely, Kendra Sunderland.
- We are gonna play
- [In Unison] "Never Have I Ever"
- I honestly have never
played this game before.
- I always lose this game.
- Never have I ever faked an orgasm.
- In porn they're always like, "Cum now".
So you're like "Aheh".
- One time 'cause I couldn't.
I was just having a rough day
and I'm still bothered about it.
- Me too.
- I worked on a volleyball--
like a sand volleyball court.
Moving sand.
And, we're just gonna leave that there.
Yeah you gotta fake it.
- I fake cum when I'm bored.
- Never have I ever dated a costar.
- Boom yeah!
- I have not.
- Neither have I.
I dunno, I felt like it
would mess with my work
like I would think about her and it would
mess with my performance.
- I say that all the time.
- Since I got into porn,
I've had the same boyfriend
and he has been in one
video before so I guess,
by default, I have.
- I mean, I'm not totally
against it but I have not.
- I have not, I have not.
I am happy that I have not.
- Never have I ever gotten
off to scenes I'm in.
- Those are my favorite!
- What? All the time!
- Definitely!
- It's creepy but I'm like,
"Get it girl, get it".
- Oh!
- Me and my boyfriend like to watch it.
But I would never go back
and like watch my own video
because that's just weird.
- Why do people watch porn?
Because it's their fantasy.
- Exactly.
- So if I'm gonna watch
it, I'm gonna watch myself
and it's not a fantasy, it's real.
- Actually, I edit all
my own scenes in movies
so when I'm editing, a lot of the time,
I have to masturbate because I'm like...
- Never have I ever slept with a fan.
- It's a yes and a no.
It's a boom and a boom.
- It's complicated.
- Yeah.
- I don't sleep with fans
but I sleep with people
and find out they're fans later.
- I guess I will say I have.
- Ooh, okay.
- It's this.
This is the confusing, we don't know.
- So I think in the moment, we didn't know
so it doesn't count.
- I don't think I have.
- Seriously?
- Nah. I don't think. Not yet.
- Never have I ever lied
about my profession.
- Yeah, sometimes you
don't want to explain it.
- Unfortunately, out in the street
it's incredibly stigmatized.
Sometimes you just want to get
your groceries and go home.
- So proud.
What?
- I have a thing that I do on
the side and I make furniture.
So, I work in wood.
- Technically that's not a lie.
Deception.
- I'm an event planner.
- Yeah, I'm a dentist.
- Never have I ever gotten bored of sex.
- Awh, there's always way to spice it up.
But I get--
- Move on?
- I've never gotten
bored of sex in general.
It's just a person or the
actual moment and then I just...
- First time I lost my virginity,
I actually started daydreaming.
- 'Cause I'll pay attention
and then 30 seconds,
I'm looking at the spider in the corner.
- Never have I ever had
a family member admit
to watching one of my scenes.
- Two of my brothers, my
nephews have all told me
that they watched my porn.
- It was a family member who really thinks
I'm going to burn in Hell.
They're very very religious.
- My momma told me, "I made that.
That's why you do it good like that".
I was done.
When I go home for the
holidays, I'm like...
"I've seen your little movie.
I made that. That's why you good."
I'm like, "Oh my god.
Mom, right now really?"
"Can I eat some turkey first?"
- So did you learn anything
about yourself or about me?
- I learned that you're pretty cool.
You're very open, very sexy.
- I have had fun.
- Me too.
(both laughing)
(funky, bouncy jazz music)